good evening everyone i'm hugh hewitt in
the
kirby center of hillsdale college in the
shadow of the capitol in the heart of
washington d.c this is the learning
center for hillsdale
where members of congress come to
improve upon their knowledge of the
constitution which is sort of an endless
task
and where the graduate school of
hillsdale college gathers to
bring in their graduate students and dr
arn on my left is a graduate of arkansas
state university
claremont graduate school where he got
his master's in his ph.d
dr copeland is a graduate of michigan
state university we got his phd
and he is did i say the chair of the
education department
all right let me start gentlemen with
the barney school uh charter school
initiative
larry ron you were telling me a story
before as to how it began
and it began with steve barney talking
to you about a problem
what was that a little before him uh i
used to get a lot of people come up to
me and poke
someone would poke me in the chest and
say you have to do something about k-12
education
and that's not exactly the business
we're in and so
i would say what you know and and uh
john walton who died not longer green
bray of the walton family
uh milton friedman
and i said to him one time i said okay
milton what we could contribute is
how to run a school and i said he said
won't competition take care of that and
i said
if there was an international
competition how to teach
economics do you think you would win
and he said i see i said so
if you know maybe you could start better
so
john walton died john walton was a
billionaire of course
and a very fine man his green beret in
the vietnam
uh but he was killed in a plane crash so
i didn't know that then steve barney
years later
four or five years later uh i was at his
house in florida
and he pointed at a school across the
street street
and he started crying because he'd been
over to that school
and he saw that the kids who were mostly
hispanic kids
in a you know ritzy place but this is
where the poor kids went uh
they weren't learning anything and he
started poking them in
and steve barney who's a dear friend of
mine and a
now emeritus trustee of the college he
said
you have to do something about and then
he cried like a baby
and i said well i've thought of
something and that was we would help
charter schools get better
and help them succeed and so that's how
it got started
and that is why it's called the barney
that's right charter school initiative
at hilltale dr copeland
uh can you briefly review for us exactly
what its scope is today as it grows year
over year
yeah so we have um uh on my 24
schools uh i'm around the country um in
11 states and we're expanding all the
time
we're typically adding in two to three
schools per year
we're reaching you know around 1400
students and we have
uh you know i mean a long waiting list a
number of these schools have
have graduates of hillsdale college who
are teaching in the classroom
kind of passing on the education they
received
at hillsdale college so it's expanding
quickly
um and we're trying to do our best you
know to
help that continue now what we're going
to do tonight is invite a lot of
audience participation so i want to give
the phone number and make sure that
everyone is available to
call us i've got instead the holocron
which dr arm was telling me to watch
earlier
the phone number is triple h 43739
if you want to help contribute to the
barney charter school initiative we'd
love
you to be a contributor because there is
a dollar for dollar match tonight
for every contribution to the endowment
of the initiative which we would like to
get up to the place where this
initiative continues to grow
across the united states triple eight
four three seven
thirty nine forty one we can go to
hillsdale.edu
town hall if you'd like to ask a
question when i come to the question
part for the audience
hit pound three to get in the queue
pound
three star three excuse me star three to
get in the queue
or send us your internet question
they'll be screened for me and i'll come
to you about that
immediately after now dr ryan i'm a
little bit surprised given hillsdale's
classical curriculum
that i don't know this after talking to
you on air for so many years but what is
a
classical charter school as opposed to
an
ordinary charter school well it's a
difference in intelligence
[Laughter]
so what is the classic time right why do
we in learning why do we refer to
something that happened in greece in the
fourth and fifth centuries bc
well the answer is philosophy was born
there
in the person of socrates and his
students plato and then his grand
student aristotle
and others and what was distinctive
about it
was that socrates wanted to know what
things are
he didn't want to just know what the law
says they are
or what our tradition or our people say
they are
he wanted to know what things are and
the most important thing he wanted to
know
was what is it for a thing to be good
and the great socratic dialogues
are about that and that means that you
seek
knowledge of nature and yourself
that is written in the laws of nature
and nature's god
and you start out like that and and so
that's the
ultimate goal of classical education but
of of course
you have to learn to read and write and
and add and subtract before you can do
that
and here's the interesting thing about
school
there are certain subjects in school
that are exp direct expressions of the
human capacity
and they are called reading writing and
arithmetic
only human beings can do those things
and all human beings can do them
and and they don't like once you start
talking in principle you can read and
you can compute
and nobody ever teaches you to talk but
the thing is you should get good at all
those things
and so classical education seeks to
develop
the talent in their students the company
develop a native capacity
to a state of excellence so they can
read
shakespeare for enjoyment and do
calculus
and also read plato
and understand that it's an exciting
drama
so that's what dr copeland i love
learning tonight that you taught at high
school before you got your phd i did
because you bring then to your students
a real world knowledge of a public high
school correct were you teaching at the
high school level i was i was a high
school spanish teacher okay so how does
a typical public high school different
from a hillsdale charter school that
came out of the barney charter school
initiative
yeah well i think schools um i mean many
schools
in the united states have just you know
they've lost their way there's so many
different things that schools can be
doing and
and the education community has been
willing to pursue those things
um and in doing those things i think
it's kind of lost its way
um it's interesting we call it classical
education about a hundred years ago you
would just call it
education right and it was actually
knowing something
um and and i think schools
in america for a long time um up until
you know the 1900s
um when there's a big shift i think it
was about the
the cultivation of not just the mind
um and knowing things um you know being
able to reason carefully
but it was also you know the cultivation
of the heart as well you were
cultivating out citizens you were
cultivating your neighbors
um and so classical education i like to
say
is about the cultivation of wisdom and
virtue
that the head and the heart and
we have a long tradition of doing that
in the western tradition we know how to
do that and we know
that there are certain things that you
need to study you need to know
in order to be an educated self
you know governed human being and so
classical education is an effort to
recover that
now i don't want to go on a jeremiah
against the public schools but i'm going
to a little bit here because of the
great fracture that we're living through
the covid crisis
and the failure of public education
pretty much across the united states to
cope
with the the children's needs and dr
i don't know what the hillsdale charter
schools have done through this i know
what hillsdale's attempted to do which
is to maintain
in-person teaching whenever they can but
this great fracture brings with it a
great opportunity there are a lot of
people listening tonight
who would like to start a school they
after the complete failure of the school
in their community
so if if that's someone who's listening
tonight what do they do
well if you uh you know first of all
call us
ask for the barney charter school
initiative we will tell you what the
steps are if you live in a state that
has an acceptable
charter school and that's a little over
half the stat chartered law that's a
little over half the states
then we can coach you through getting
the school founded
and uh you know that all of the 24
schools
that's how they started we we don't own
the schools
because there's this weird thing about
us we don't take any money from the
government
and these are public schools and that
means that
of these 24 schools we've spent now many
great
number of dollars on them over 10 years
now
none of us ever paid us five cents for
anything
if their teachers come and stay on our
campus 500 of them come
every summer when they're on the campus
we pay for everything
and that means that we don't own the
schools either we have a contract
with the people who started it and we
will help you
if you will pursue the aims and methods
that we lay out
if you commit to the goal of
establishing a classical charter school
you will help them
if you want to dial in the discussion
and submit a question 877-229-8493
and then enter the code 116266
and then the pound sign i'm going to
repeat that slowly for the pittsburgh
steeler fans
the phone number is 877 229
84 93 then the code is
116 266 and the pound sign
and then to get in the queue star three
now uh dr copeland i don't know if you
agree with my
estimate of what has happened out there
but i do think there's this opportunity
right now
people have seen their children at home
staring at the zoom screen not learning
anything and they want
somehow to cope how have the charter
schools coped with the crisis
yeah well so uh you know as charter
schools go
they need an approval either through um
you know local body
or more often than not through the state
um in the state it kind of establishes
um you know who who can open a charter
school how you can actually do this so
a lot of our charter schools um i think
they have the same spirit that we do
at hillsdale college is that if we can
be open we're going to be open
and so a lot of these schools are trying
to stay open but at the same time
they have to follow the laws of that
particular state and so if the state is
not allowing them to
then they're going to do the best that
they possibly can and they're going to
use
everything at their disposal to provide
children with a quality classical
education
but again you know these are public
schools and they have to follow the
policies of the state
so the state will dictate what they can
actually do now i want to close before i
go to the first email question and to
the phones
we were talking before about the number
of teachers that hillsdale college
produces
and where they go and the number of
schools that come to recruit
at hillsdale and would you pass on that
bit because i i want every educator
who's listening out there to know that
where they want to come and find
teachers is hillsdale yeah well we
graduate
350 seniors a year and
something over 10 percent of them go and
be school teachers
and they a lot of them are don't intend
to do that for their lives because
you know it's a pretty fancy pants
college and they can do what they want
to
uh i encourage them if they're going to
go into that world to become like dan
copeland
to become a teacher of teachers and a
manager of schools
but they start out teachers and so we
have a classical jobs fair
every year and we get like 60 schools
from all over the country come and set
up a
booth and the ones from florida put sand
on their table and pictures of sunshine
it's in january we put giant mosquitoes
and that's all yeah
you know it's the same ones that we
always invite you right so then
if a kid if any of our seniors walk in
there
whoever he is or she is they will walk
out with four or five job offers
and uh and they you know they it
it's a it's a great thing by the way you
learn so much from your students
and they graduate and they're very
successful people
and then they become a school teacher
four months later
and they find out that's the devil of a
problem
humility you've got to stand up and talk
for
six or seven hours a day and grade
papers at night
and so they live in an emergency for
months
and they grow up fast and that is a
wonderful thing again
remember if you want to dial in a
contribution triple eight four
three seven thirty nine forty one
because the barney school initiative
must prosper our first email comes from
peter reimers
in wichita kansas what is a charter
school in contrast to a public school or
a private school
i'll give that to you dr copeland yeah
so a charter school
is is a public school um it relies
um on on the support
uh of the local community and
and so therefore it must meet the
demands of that community and of the
state
what makes uh a charters
a rich environment to provide this kind
of education is that
because they are a charter school they
are given freedoms in terms
of you know being able to choose a
particular you know kinds of curriculum
they're relieved from other standards
that the local public school may not
have to meet
um but that said they still are going to
be held accountable
um to the local citizenry to the state
and so they have to complete
you know standardized tests they have to
show um
you know to the state as good as those
tests are um
um you know that they're improving and
their students are improving they're
learning to read they're learning to
compute and
you know all of those things so the
charter
school environment is an environment
where choices can be made
much more at the school level where you
have a school board
making choices and giving the
administrators um leeway to be able
you know to provide the kind of
curriculum that will really make a
difference in these students lives
do you want to add something that the
defining difference to understand the
public schools just remember what the
revolution is right
because charter schools are actually
operating the way in a good state where
the charter law is good
they're operating the way schools
everywhere operated 100 years ago
but now just think of to absorb this
fact
a majority of the employees of public
education in america
are not teachers in a charter school
it's one non-teacher for every six or
seven
teachers and so we're spending more much
more than
half the money in the public schools on
things that never get to the classroom
and it tends to be true that the higher
paid people
are in the bureaucracies and what their
job is is to tell them what to do in the
schools all the time
now we are both old enough to be
grandparents and you are a recent
grandfather
dr aaron so all the hillsdale college
people can clap that
and that poor child i think ahead to
those years but i
i am very concerned with where they do
school and i follow very closely the
choices that are made and i
advise my children if they're going to
raise a family move to the school
would you do the same thing would you
say do not trap yourself in a school
system
that is a public school only well
code values uh vary all over america
with the reputed
excellence of the school because you
know parents
want one you know it turns out even in
this weird day and age
parents love their children it's a
strange thing and they
they didn't love them more than they
love children they don't know
yes strangely it's hard and i mean you
know
my granddaughter is you know three days
old and
obviously much better than york
the argument breaks into a fight
so yeah and see in a in a charter school
here's something different from the
parent
point of view first of all you can find
out
all about it before you go they've all
got
a presentation to give you about what
your child is going to learn
about how we're going to go about it
about the honor code your child has to
sign and in almost all cases and the
others were working on
the honor code that you the parent has
to sign
and then you become that day a partner
in the school
whereas a parent and a teacher in an
ordinary school have in common
they were operating at the bottom of a
vast bureaucracy
looking up trying to get someone to pay
attention before i go back to you and
susan lewis i'll come direct dr copeland
question on many people mind is can can
we win can
education be salvaged in the united
states or are these little islands of
excellence
simply going to be an archipelago of
lighthouses and a long rocky coast on
which every other ship wrecks
yeah i i absolutely have to believe that
to be the case
i mean if you're an educator you believe
in hope um and if you don't you should
get out of it
um so yes i think um absolutely
there is hope and and i would argue even
in the last
20 years that these kinds of schools
that we're trying to start and
you know we're not alone in this there
are other people who are trying to
cultivate classical education
in the private school community and in
the charter school community
but i think that just the success that
we have had
even in the last 10 years has encouraged
you know traditional public schools
around these schools to up their game
because we're doing it so well you would
think every public school board in the
country would be coming to you susan
lewis in virginia
asked could you recommend some books or
curriculum materials for u.s histories
in grade k
through 12. that's a big question dr
erin
you know thank god you asked that
question this year
because there has been published this
year
by a man who's taking up employment at
hillsdale college next year
bill mcclay a brilliant the best ever
written history american history
textbook
it's called land of hope and even if you
don't have kids you should
call up and buy get to get a copy of
that thing and read it
because it is great and it is the
antidote to these
crazy howard zen like textbooks that are
used today
but you know the the trouble with with
with any particular textbook is unless
it's adopted by one of the major
school systems in the united states it
languages although if you can get this
one adopted
land of hope in charter schools
everywhere do charter schools have the
authority over their textbooks
they do well most states right most
states yeah yeah and uh
and see that's another thing right in
other words just remember
everything in america is described by
this
government in america used to proceed
from the bottom
up and that meant things in the
community were decided in the community
things in the state the state
national things only federal schools
worked that way from the northwest
ordinance in 1787
the land in each township was given to
the state government by the federal
government to fund education
in that township you see and so
this charter schools in the best states
florida is a really good state and
here the governor of florida is a hero
and the secretary of education there
corcoran is a hero and the former
speaker michael baleka is a hero
right those are great people and what
they've done is
they have set the conditions so that we
can recover the old way of running
america
we have thousands of people listening
right now a reminder to ask a question
about the barney school charter the
barney charter school initiative just
press
star three on your phone's keypad okay
let's go to our next question
helen gobert from garden grove
california you are on the line go ahead
helen
i have benefited greatly from learning
latin
in sixth grade until i graduated from
high school and i want to know what the
latin is taught at the barney school and
what other subjects are taught there
dr copeland yes it is yes
so one of the core features of a
classical education is
that students learn latin and of course
we have our students that begin by you
know being able to learn to read
in their native language english and
then we teach them english grammar
as well but in the elementary grades we
begin to introduce
latin and it's important for them you
know to study that
not only are there um a large percentage
of english words
that have latin at their base at their
core at their root
but the ability to or
or the discipline that it takes for one
to study a language
like latin which is so logical
um and and its pieces fit together
in such a beautiful way the discipline
required to study a language like that
will apply to others things beyond just
latin itself so absolutely we have it
leo i hope uh or whatever it is i can't
remember it anymore but but
i hope that every does every one of the
barney schools
every single one it's required of all
yeah that is terrific that's actually
terrific
ah doctor on this one comes from michael
cotter of texas
what challenges will we face with
charter schools under a
biden administration uh well it's a
mortal threat
uh it's an interesting thing you know
bill clinton
was open to charter schools
obama favored them these guys
promised to put a sp stop to it and
you know they they i'm confident they
will do it if they have the power
the structure of things is uh you know
there's two americas
and they're at war with each other so
almost all of
the money that's been on education is
raised and spent
inside state boundaries in the typical
state
education is 60 percent of the state
budget
now the federal government puts what is
relatively speaking a pittance in
but there are lots of conditions and
when they make the conditions then the
teachers union and the state and
people who think that everything ought
to be the same everywhere in the country
they rally up behind it
and so if they start putting pressure on
federal funding
to an excellent charter school state
the the the people who favor the charter
schools and the charter schools
themselves will come under
pressure and the question is can they
resist that pressure
well i'll just tell you a fact that's a
great fact and that is uh
remember what i said before about how
there's kind of a fact in nature
that parents love their children ron
desantis
was elected governor of uh
florida by about 45 000 votes
and he got 60 000 more votes
from black women than it ever been
recorded for a republican
and he got that by can campaigning
around the voucher and charter schools
in the inner cities
that he had helped to get founded and he
said they're going to take your school
so the point is people will fight for
their charter school they'll fight for
their good schools they'll fight for
their children they will
so although i've read the same promises
uh beginning with with some pretty
radical things
but people ought just to demand of their
state and local authorities resistance
uh we will capture that term you know
the executive branch is way too powerful
now
but and they can do a lot of mischief
just even if they don't get the senate
to get the senate all bets are off we'll
watch georgia closely okay i thank you
for that a reminder to all of you
listening to ask a question about the
barnier
barney charter school initiative just
press star 3
on your phone's keypad let's go to our
next question nancy mcconkey
from speaking of florida from florida
live on the line hello nancy
hi there thank you for taking my
question um
to the uh tartar charter schools provide
an option
for home school students that is do they
provide a covering for
families is that a part of your program
uh well the answer is uh
yes we uh the barney's
all of this k-12 education stuff we're
doing has gotten huge and it's growing
and it's morphing all the time
because the demand is simply enormous
and so we are busy right now
adapting our curriculum for homeschool
people and then we're going to make that
available to them for free
and then we're going to do online things
to help them be good at that or better
at that
and we've already got some thousands of
people
every week who get together and
or groups of homeschoolers who use the
college's online courses
as instruction tools and so the point is
we want to get
you know you want to know the theory of
education
the sovereign body is the school because
in the school
is gathered the students and the parents
and the teachers in other words all the
people who love each other
make the thing work homeschooling is
just a smaller
example of the same thing and it works
great
and it could be that one will have to
flee to homeschool and you know there
are states where that too
is technology is enabling it every day
if you have not yet been to hilldale.edu
uh just go go and and search it out
find where it is what are the colleges
costs in supporting these schools
uh well it depends on whether they're
lying to me or not but um
it's running at about 100 about 1.7
million dollars a year now
and uh and you know we could spend much
more than that
and uh you know there's 14
people working on this full-time uh
and then the faculty many of the faculty
members led by professor copeland here
who's
a treasurer of american education if i
do say so myself
uh they've just adopted this thing they
just love this thing
and and so the whole college is behind
it and we spend a lot on it and we give
it a lot of effort
if you're listening this call i would
really appeal to you in addition to the
questions we'd like your contributions
and you can make those at triple eight
four three seven thirty nine
forty one then go to hillsdale.edu town
hall and the reason i say that is we got
a wonderful generous one dollar for one
dollar match
and it goes into the endowment of the
hillsdale
college barney charter school initiative
so that it can do more and last longer
because it's not a short-term
thing um for you dr copeland from nancy
aronson
uh watching on facebook what sort of
preparation or continuing learning do
teachers at the bcsi
schools complete and continue to
complete
yeah so we um with our schools we look
for
you know students who are smart um
they know their field you know they know
their subject matter well
but not just that we want them to be
broadly educated as well
so we want them to have a broad liberal
education and so our schools
look to hire these kinds of people
and bring them on board but it's not
just people who are smart it's people
who
who understand the power of a liberal
education and want to give that
to young people want to pass it along
you know this great tradition of liberal
learning so what we do at the college is
uh um
we will continue to serve um
you know these teachers where they are
so we have a group of people
through our k-12 initiative who actually
go out and observe them
in the classroom give them feedback
answer their questions
while on the ground of course people are
always
calling into our k-12 office you know to
get advice
and feedback but then we have this most
amazing thing
at the end of june we have a two-week
period where we invite
all of these teachers whether it's from
arizona whether it's from colorado
florida where
and we invite them to come to
hillsdale's campus because we want them
to interact
with each other yeah yeah with each
other
with the faculty of the college and we
bring them to campus in fact
uh last summer even though you know
covid was going on
and all the restrictions we had more
than 300 teachers
come to hillsdale's campus uh to
continue their education to spend time
with our faculty to spend time with each
other
to talk about the best way to teach you
know
you know civics um american history um
english grammar geometry whatever thank
you
and to have that conversation and so the
last two weeks of june
we invest all of our time and we spend
time with them
you know teaching them learning from
them um
a couple of weeks it is indeed it is
there are 13
000 people on this call right now and so
i'm gonna go to my next question but i
would just ask each of the 13
000 if you'd each give a hundred bucks
or 200
or 500 we could fund an entire year's
effort if you would if you're listening
to this call you know how important this
initiative is that
dr aaron and the team in hillsdale do
not undertake new programs or
initiatives lightly 24 schools
24 schools it could be 48 it could be
whatever twice that is 96 did i get that
right uh
dr george schoder uh from
armand beach florida is live on the line
i hope i pronounce your name correctly
dr
schoder uh it doesn't seem to be an r in
there but welcome
go ahead doctor well it is schroeder
hugh and it's
that was larry's privilege
thank you good to talk to you well uh
first of all
um good to talk to you too you're um
first of all like to say uh god bless
you
dr arn and hillsdale college in our
sixth decade of life
we are still students uh by means of in
primus
and in primus is such a wonderful
resource that
uh hillsdale offers and i'm still a
student as a
green-parted canadian who was
naturalized as a us citizen
ten years ago i'm still learning about
american civic and this is such an
important subject
that all natural born americans ought to
be educated about
and is this part of your core curriculum
and then i have a final part of the
question which is
basically concerns common core
um and what your views are as to
um you know what these mandates
that are being posed by government
onto free thinking colleges dr schroeder
said that that is a three-part question
uh but i'm going to boil it down to two
which is uh the common core
and dr arndt loves the common core and
and uh
what was the first part of it it was the
uh oh
uh core curriculum and and the
constitution in america
yeah so i'll answer them in the order of
the core curriculum first so hillsdale
college was founded to be 175 years ago
in the world conquest business we're
supposed to save the world
and we have a weapon and we only have
one and that's teaching
and so we undertake to teach anyone who
wants to learn
from us we can't do it in all cases but
they're
put it all together 2.6 million people
taking one pound of course or another
from hillsdale college
and we never charge a nickel for it and
i like to say
we lose our shirts on undergraduate
education which we charge for although
not nearly what it cost
whereas if we give things away free it
works out fine and uh
so that yeah and we we think you know
the whole charter school initiative
the reason dan copeland and i are
friends and i dare say the reason hugh
hewitt and i
our friends were 35 or 40 years now
a long time is because we think that
there are things
of fundamental importance that are
common to all human beings
we also think it's beautiful to learn
about those things it it it
raises the soul and it secures the
freedom
and so what should be taught in school
is those things
and the skills required to grasp them
and it's it's not even all that
complicated so that's your first answer
the answer is
we you know one one year somebody said
i said i think we're going to have to do
private schools and they said but you
said we couldn't and i said i did say
that
and they said well you don't like us
changing the scope of things
and then my colleague david whalen very
close friend as well
he said to me he said you're changing
your mind about something
and i said i am i said i've had these
people
three sets up in my office this week and
they're
dying to learn or us to help them learn
shouldn't we try right so there's the
answer to that yeah
i i received the galleys this week from
my dear friend
archbishop chape of his new book things
worth dying for and i read them because
you got to blurb them you've written
four books and dr arne knows what you go
through the process you send them to
people who might
and his last chapter is on friendship
his last chapter is on aristotle and
cicero and on friendship
and friendship is at the core of
education i believe you've told me that
repeatedly that the best education comes
from between
by and through friends and i like dr
schroeder he's a friend of the college
he's a friend of him prime minister he's
our friend that's right these are
friends who are
who are supporting the college in a new
initiative and i would really encourage
you triple eight 437-394
to be a friend of the next generation
who cannot make it with this
education system unrepaired from our
live youtube stream at this point comes
maria bertucci good irish lady
how is hillsdale k-12 helping children
to develop the type of personal
independence on which
political independence rests thank you
jessie
former history teacher and head of
school dr copeland
well that's kind of difficult to answer
here when i have a dr aaron here
um pay no attention to that behind the
curtain no this is his expertise
right uh um well i think it begins um
with uh you know teaching you know
students uh
the idea that learning is hard work um
and that
it actually requires you to sacrifice
you know something um your time your
energy your effort
and that starts in the earliest grades
that kind of well-ordered
experience and so you know we're going
to talk about u.s history we're going to
talk about
you know civics and all of these key
ideas and the ideas that we love
and that we've rallied behind but i i
would argue it starts
even how we educate and how we do
education
um and and you you know the concept
of a delayed gratification right um
and all of those things have been lost
um
in education and i think that's kind of
part of what we're trying to recover
here you know uh in t.h white's the once
in future king
i don't know if you two are fans of that
i love it i love listening to it
merlin says to young wart that the only
certain cure for sadness is to learn
something
that's the only way out of the pit of
that and i just think it's wonderful uh
remember you donate to hillsdale there
is a dollar for dollar match
right now again that phone number to
donate four three seven thirty nine
forty one
okay let's go to our next question karen
roland is from tallahassee
florida live on the line one of the 13th
they're all from florida tonight hello
karen how are you
well thank you for taking my column very
well and i'm very happy to be
speaking with you tonight i have a
question um
i my daughter is very fortunate to be at
part of
this brand new school in tallahassee and
unfortunately as a parent i did not have
this type of education
so i'm looking for resources how do i
where do i
turn to learn about what she's learning
so that i can help her with all of her
education opportunities well dr copeland
left up your alley yeah i think
you know a great place to start is that
to look at what your child
is learning read what your child is
reading you know
one of the greatest opportunities as a
parent is just to engage
in conversation around the dinner table
have
have a dinner conversation what did you
talk about today in class
a lot of what we talk about in classical
education has to do with the idea of
posing questions um
and discussing answers you know the
socratic dialogue having a conversation
and so
i would start there have that kind of
conversation we have some great
resources
at hillsdale that you know if you go to
our website
um we have some recommended reading you
know that you can do and that'll
help any parent to be able to frame
these questions
and have these kinds of conversations um
but
it's about conversation let me let me go
again
dial star 3 if you're on the line you
want to ask a question bob
canteen from tennessee go ahead robert
all right my question is can you share a
little
information with us on how the charter
school
is governed and how they if there is a
board how it's constituted
yeah we're uh learning about that while
we go
first of all you want so there is a
governing board
the schools have a contract with us that
we will help them and spend money
on them without compensation back to us
if they will pursue the aims and methods
that we've
defined together so for that's the first
element of governance in a charter
school
then as dan mentioned earlier there's
the state law and then third there's a
board
and you have to have a board because you
know hillsdale college has the greatest
board
on earth i argue i work for them but
they relieve me of a conflict of
interest because i have the executive
authority in the college
and i get paid for it and so if i make
the ultimate positions
uh decisions who's to say i need
somebody to answer to
they don't get paid so that's the first
function of a board
the second function is they need to be
people of good judgment
who can help govern the school which is
different from managing it
and who can steer it with can you expand
on that difference
for just a moment because if people are
getting excited about becoming a board
member i want
because i i serve at the whim of the
board as well two of them
and i want them to understand the
difference between governing and
managing that's
the most important thing and you know by
the way if you turn out to work for
non-profit boards and i've had a
distorted life i've always done that and
i never set out to
i figured out how to do it along the way
so first of all
today the big subject while i was coming
to washington dc
was what are we going to give the
college newspaper
for its final edition and uh
you know and it turns out it's a little
sensitive because sure it is
we've had lots of rules imposed on us by
the government
and we don't like it and we say so
and so we and you know that's a little
risky because the government's powerful
and so it's about that right and we
contrived all that with some care
the board can't do that right and then
our board meets three times a year uh i
give them a report
i always go in a certain order i always
talk about mistakes
first there's always a list
then i talk about problems things that
are
worrisome and then i tell them the state
of the college
and the state of the college you know
hillsdale college is awesome
and it's doing extremely well i never
say that in a board meeting
because they're supposed to think
and help me and you know they mostly
what they think they're gonna do because
i've been there a long time and these
people are friends of mine too
but they're serious people you know one
of the guys who hired me
was the most successful ceo of kellogg
corporation after mr kellogg
and that guy is he lives in florida his
name is bill the mouth
that guy is brilliant he's also a model
of good character i work for people like
that
and so if people aspire to be on a board
and you want to govern
you bring character commitment and
sacrifice
and you do not intend to manage the
people you can't
and you know what you do in the way of
management is uh
fire and hire the ceo
and you know i'm on a bunch of
non-profit boards now you know one of my
kids just got hired to be the president
of an old conservative foundation called
isi oh wonderful and i you know and
that's my boy right and he's just a
little punk and
and uh don't tell the board i'm on the
board
and you know he's so i want him to work
for a good board
who knows they can't manage the thing
yeah and i want him
you know he's my kid right i've known
him since he was 18.
and so he's very by the way precocious
he's
he's good at it already but you know
once a while they ask me a question i'll
say okay
you asked me for advice because that
would be your call
and it doesn't matter what advice i give
you you'll be responsible for the call
yeah i mean he gets it in heartbeat
management and government
from i want to go to this one in
scottsdale arizona andrea wargo
has sent us an email because arizona is
a healthy place for charter schools
they are a volcano doug ducey's done a
lot for charter schools but even the
governors before
doug ducey and there are lots of them i
know there are lots of hillsdale
graduates down there teaching
how can hillsdale influence public and
private education at a national level to
include
patriotic themes and andrea wargo is a
president's club
diamond member i know that woman you do
and she's probably been at the events
that we've done in arizona and she wants
as i do patriotism not nationalism uh
i'll let you do that one daniel because
i've heard him answer it before and then
he can just correct you
yeah i think um you know going back to
uh
you know the problems in uh in american
education at today
um our our teachers and our educators
have been trained to tear down to tear
down to tear down
um and i think that as a profession
educators need to be able to to
recognize the faults in the wards
but they also need to show how to honor
uh
what's great about america and so you
know one of the great
things about being an educator is that
it's not just what you say
it's also how you live your life because
i i tell my students the students are
always watching
right so we need a population
of teachers who are willing to to honor
what's good from our tradition
and live that out and then we need to
teach
american history at every level not just
social studies but american history we
have to know
where we came from um you know it's a
cliche in order to understand where
we're going
and so i think there needs to be a
recovery of american history at every
level all the way down to the
kindergarten grades so
so we often have people um talk to me
about teaching
civics and so i remind people we have a
dollar for dollar match right now thanks
to a generous donor
you've got to call triple h seven thirty
nine
forty one triple eight four three seven
thirty nine forty one
our next question on the line is dr dean
foreman from
roseville california good evening dr
foreman welcome
thank you it's good to be with you and
uh
thank you again to dr r and dr copeland
for
having the vision and will to see
something through
uh my question is and it relates to what
was said earlier and that is
graduating 350 scholars every year and
10 of them maybe end up teaching and
you know in the charter school world
we're always faced with the dilemma of
how does a generation
never educated in the classics educate a
new generation in the classics
and how do we find the leaders and
teachers because to open up these
schools
we need to broaden this the scope and
the vision of this to
other schools and i wondered what uh
what you're observing are there others
that are coming online or coming about
doing this
and if so who are they and if not how
can we broaden this
idea of a liberal arts education one
that is full of patriotism
and full of a love for america expand
so uh i confess to all of our people
gathered on this call that uh dean
foreman is a buddy of mine
uh we're up to 14 000 people on the call
okay i now know the information
nadine is the founder and head of the
john adams
academy uh north of sacramento
and uh it's an awesome school and he's
an awesome guy
and the answer is question he already
knows
the actual fastest method of building
and multiplying
a movement is not tv tv commercials
it's teaching and the reason is
yeah we have 350 a year graduate
we're about to start a master's degree
program in classical education
to train leaders for these schools and
everyone is going to teach thousands
and then of those thousands
a number a high number if you do it
right
fall in love and it changes their life
and they become a light to all
and i i will i'll say i've never seen a
more dangerous time than right now in
america
i've never seen a more opportune time
for learning
because now things seem serious
are we going to keep our freedom how do
we keep it
do we deserve it what about the people
who say that we don't deserve it
right how are you going to answer them
in other words it's a
it's a rich world right now for
reaching people and teaching themselves
you know on that note and
apropos of being able to read the
supreme court ruled this week by
a six to three decision in which my
friend
five to four decisions excuse me my
friend the chief justice was on the
wrong side
of decision about whether or not
churches could open uh in new york
and it pains me that people didn't read
the decision because they thought it was
too difficult to read it's about
everybody's liberty and so
fundamentally as dr unlike say
fundamental things are afoot and if
people don't understand them they can't
decide them
that's it there are 14 000 people on the
line watching online on youtube and
facebook let's go to our next question
marty gargarro from mackinac city
in that state up north as we say in ohio
hello marty
hello how are you this evening terrific
my question
is what kind of what kind of safeguards
do you have in place
to keep your principles from going
off the rails as these schools develop
because we know that you get enough
people together they change
things and i mean it basically happened
to our country and it happened to the
school system doctor copeland that's a
great question how do you stop it
yeah it's a great question marty you
don't want it to become a cult
that's right no personality leadership
how do you how do you do that
yeah so um it comes through
communication
you know um keeping the group small
enough so that you know actually
what's going on i mean we're hillsdale
college and even though
we have a large reach we're a relatively
small campus i mean at 1400 students and
and when you have a campus of that size
you know people
and and you have conversations and i
think you know that that's
important at the local level as well
with these schools
these k-12 schools is communication um
and accountability and we're talking
about school boards and
and administrators holding people
accountable and in a revisiting
um what drives you i was on a school
board for
you know three years and and we
instituted a practice
of reading the mission statement at the
beginning of the school board
you know meeting just to reorientate
ourselves that whatever policy came our
way
we're going to read that mission
statement and we better be able to
justify our choice
you know based on that mission so that's
an excellent idea another question again
if you want to ask one dial star three
on your phone
bobby welch from baton rouge louisiana
hello bobby you're on with dr arn dr
copeland and me hugh hewitt
i i am a retired educator um
now living in savannah georgia but a
long time
proponent of school choice and friends
with robert in low and
the friedrin foundation and all of that
history that
they have developed there but my
i have a in looking at charter schools
and
from a multiple pers multiple
perspectives
two questions continue to
be problematic for me and seemingly for
those schools
one of those is on the issue of
um the course of study when it isn't
a public school the requisite testing
programs
naep and others like that
state testing as well as national
testing
in my experience has frequently
created such a distraction and hardship
that it is
almost impossible to maintain a robust
classical school course of study
that's one issue that i'd like to know
how barney schools address
and the second is to your question to
your thought that you address both the
head
and the heart on the heart side of that
it is
so difficult in the charter schools that
i've worked with and known about
to get at ethical behavior and morality
without
having the biblical basis from which to
to work you do have the benefit of great
literature uh if you're reading and
studying
iliad of the odyssey and pilgrim's
progress and other
great literature pieces but you don't
have biblical truth and
so i'm curious to know how the barney
schools address
the heart part so testing and
theology dr aaron want to go first well
you're right about the testing and
that would be good yes i love the curse
that um
that's partly a republican innovation
and i will tell you that sitting to my
left here professor copeland is the man
who has the solution to that
states should test some
they have a responsibility to the their
citizens to see that the schools are
good
but the test should be simple and chosen
to teach
to demonstrate basic skills
instead what we got today is uh they
actually turn
the the curriculum into a badly written
instruction manual for how to repair a
lawnmower
and it's just it's just deadly dull i
have seen
sample classes coming out of the common
core
and there's a thing the teacher's
supposed to read to start the class so
first of all
these are human beings right if you walk
in a room and somebody reads you
something that's printed out by somebody
else are you going to think it's
important
so that stuff is deadly and there
should be some testing but it should not
be like it is today
uh now about the heart
the declaration dependence speaks of the
laws of nature and of nature's god
and it come to find out that the moral
things moral things are things that
concern
right and wrong good and bad and the
moral things
are the same in the bible and in the
great books
and so and you know there's no
prescription against reading the bible
you can't engage in uh religion you
can't
claim that jesus christ is the son of
god
but the bible is a tremendous piece of
literature the great majority of it
written before there was a jesus
although he's predicted christians think
in there and the point is the moral
knowledge be good right
what is it to be good what is a human
being
when it is a good human being i want
into a charter school in arizona and the
seniors are reading the brothers
karamazov
that was their senior book you will have
a moral education if you make it through
the brothers garamotsa
and understand about what you've done uh
comment on that dr coleman yeah so it um
it seems at least in the last hundred
years or so
maybe a little bit shorter that that um
schools have almost
taken the opinion to to be in opposition
uh uh to morality to religion any
conversation
because you know they're not allowed to
bring it explicitly into the classroom
they've almost gone the other direction
um and almost to be opposed to it um at
the bcsi
you know charter schools we we recognize
the importance of it we know that it's
in the curriculum it's already in there
as you described
but not only that we can encourage
parents to have those conversations at
home so we're not in opposition to it
right we can encourage
that um and encourage parents to bring
up those conversations and to make those
kinds of connections
so there's a big difference between
between opposing it and
supporting the home and having those
conversations barney charter school
initiative
needs money it needs your support if
you're on this line before i
we've got ten minutes left i remind you
triple eight is the number to call
triple eight four three seven
thirty nine forty one eight eight eight
four three seven
thirty nine forty 41 at the conclusion
of this call you can stay on the line
and
make comments or you can go to
hillsdale.edu town hall
and make a contribution there as well
harry fields is uh
sent via email he's a president's club
gold
member harry fields in tennessee ultima
tennessee
how much civics instruction do the
students receive in a barney
uh charter school yeah so it's
actually part of the curriculum um
there's a greater emphasis
obviously on it um in terms of what is
taught at the upper grades
so in the high school but as i said it's
not only taught in isolation it's
supported by the other parts of the
curriculum and that's
one of the features one of the many
features of a good classical education
is that the curriculum uh the subjects
within the curriculum
uh support one another so i i brought up
history you know
the civics is not tight as i said taught
in
isolation it's supported by history by
literature
and by the other subjects so it is how
would it enter into
english dr copeland well i i mean if
we're are you talking about english
civics yeah
so i mean if you're reading literature
right it's about
human nature it's about human being what
does it mean to be a human being
and that absolutely informs you that
you're you're hitting home run
every subject should have civics in it
in my view every subject you can put
geometry the geometry of god
i'll add some if the classics are
correct and they are
the human being is made to be a citizen
because the thing that distinguishes us
as we can talk
and because we can talk our inmost
thoughts can be communicated to other
people
and the political community is the
community that
pursues the questions of right and wrong
and so
any good novel because drama
derives from questions of right and
wrong
any good novel is a civilization that's
my
my theory now we have a special treat
2017 hillsdale alum is calling us from
okinawa japan
jessica mutard hello jessica there might
be a time delay here so go ahead
hi i have a question for dr copeland
uh could you please explain the
difference of the
full day structure in a barney charter
school
versus the conventional public school
yeah so um well one of the biggest
things that to stand out
is um is uh the idea of actually
bringing
you know the students that together at
the beginning of the day in fact i would
highly recommend
if you're able to visit one of our
schools to just go and observe that all
the students come together
um you know they do the pledge they will
do a patriotic song even
and once again that's the civics
education right
just what does it mean to be a citizen
then throughout the day it may
look a lot like a typical school in that
students are going from classroom to
classroom
in the upper grades or they're being
taught in a classroom
you know by a teacher so it would look a
lot like
what we know school to be but again
what makes these schools a different is
that they're teaching
real content and they're taught by
people who
know things and who care about their
students and are trying to live out
on a daily basis the ideas that are at
the core of a liberal education
practical question when they begin do
they begin
fully formed k through 12 or do they add
a class a year
right it really depends and and
typically you know
like any school you need to feed those
upper schools
i'm sorry the upper grades and so
typically you know they start with a few
grades
in the lower school and they build their
way up and it depends on whether they
start k4
k6 it all depends on on the students who
are
in that community and what the community
leaders
remember dr arm pointed out that we
don't come in and
start these schools this is a local
movement this is people who have come
together
around a common idea that they want they
know that they can offer something
more to their uh for their children than
is currently being
how much capital do they have to have to
begin do you think
uh well it varies um
you know in the ideal world uh
they would have 10 million dollars to
build a school building
uh that isn't really necessary
we are working with a couple of
investment firms
to put together a fund that they can
draw on
uh but we want them to prove themselves
first sure too as does the investment
fund
firm uh but yeah you need you know first
of all
just remember anything you know i i'm
i'm so
old and huge so old i knew hugh when he
was going into radio
long time 30 years ago that's like 400
years ago and and
you know he he he did it a couple of
times he liked it
and he started figuring it out right
that's how
school starts you got there's a bunch of
stuff you're going to have to do
and we can help you with that stuff
because this is not our first rodeo
but it's also true that you have to
figure it out
you have to like doing it yeah and then
to use the analogy there's a program
director up in hillsdale that will call
you up and do an air check
that's right but you still got to go do
the show that's right
let's uh let's remind people to do the
show you can help with a dollar for
dollar match tonight
437 39 41 kathleen you are so good at
producing this program otherwise it'd be
a mess
uh there's a dollar for dollar match
don't let that go by please
let's go to our next question mark goats
from port st
lucia in florida hello mark
uh good evening and uh i'd like to
congratulate dr arn on his new
granddaughter
who actually just stole my question
which was
the initial investment for a charter
school would be what
understanding that the total with the
facility would be 10 million
what would i need for an initial
investment to get into a school
well you need uh
the answer varies so the point is the
school
is going to be funded by a per capita
payment
from the state it's usually about 70
of what the public schools get and it's
enough
but then the question arises when are
they going to pay you
right and so in the best states you get
some enrollment and see you get your
enrollment you start getting an idea of
your aromas in the spring before
and these schools admission is by
lottery
right and that means uh the
wait list is about half as big as the
school itself
and that means on the day of the lottery
when people show up most of them don't
get in
well then once you know that then the
good states
will start paying you money in the
summer
the bad states later in the term
so we have a system at hillsdale college
where we make interest-free loans
to get you over the hub to schools to
get them going
right and and we don't charge interest
because then somebody would come along
and claim we're taking money from the
government
and you know it's we live in such a bad
age that is actually more profitable
to lose money to the government than it
is to take money from the government
so to try you know i i think if anyone
is sufficiently interested they ought to
go
to the website and find someone at the
barney charter school initiative and ask
them about the practical step
because there is a practical way to go
about this last
question i am told by kathleen comes
from stephanie mystery in carrollton
texas
how can we help the barney initiative we
have three sons at founders classical
academy
in louisville thank you stephanie dr
aaron how can
they help the initiative well the first
thing is tell those boys to be good
and don't be a problem to headmaster
carros
who's a buddy of mine the second is
help make that school good right
third is learn yourself
and teach others because this came up
before dan said it
the way you get a liberal education is
you read and you talk
it's by the way also the way you do
everything else
and so if you organize your life
around knowing the things that are the
best things to know
sure enough soon enough you'll know a
lot about them and then
you should teach others you should
proclaim the glories of the school
but not just that you like it explain
what they teach
and explain why it's beautiful and learn
how to do that
i want to get last thoughts from both of
you uh as you wrap up dr
copeland final thoughts for us yeah i
um i would go back to the idea of are
our schools
worth saving and they are
i again i would encourage anyone to go
by
and to visit one of these bcsi schools
it is inspiring it is hopeful to see
these young kids
learning some great things and already
being
i mean excited about their own future
about the future of this country as well
so go visit a bcsi school doctor
well this is uh you know another one of
our crazy
ideas and it's one of the best and uh
it didn't make any sense at all when we
started it
uh and i just thought it's just nutty
enough
because see we can't get reimbursed by
these schools
and we won't be right and you know it's
a funny world now because the government
tells us what to do
a lot especially during this pandemic
even though we don't take their money
but not as much as if we did i would add
that
for those of you are listening uh those
contributions matter but do not forget
in your legacy planning
uh that you can leave a specific gift to
hillsdale college and you can leave it
to the barney charter school initiative
by visiting hillsdale.edu town hall
you can also watch a video at
hillsdale.edu
town hall of this and you can send it to
other people and you can say it can be
done or if you have a question or
comment stay on the line
or leave a voicemail at the end of the
call once again i want to thank our
wonderful team
who've been working here and appointing
even as we speak towards the camera
i would love if we could turn around
they they will somehow edit that botched
opening of mind magnificently to make it
sound like
shakespeare was here on the stage and to
kathleen and your team
well done into every one of you 14 000
people
you made a difference by being here
listening and spreading the word of the
barney
charter school initiative hillsdale.edu
town hall
more comments more questions and we'll
be back next year with more progress
on the hillsdale initiative thank you
and good night
you